we have two minutes until that we need  to set up for oh hey Julie breathe kiss  me  what you create a diversion yes I don't  you can't see me she can't a little me  right George good so you wanted me to  kiss you in a police station as a way to  draw attention away from ourselves that  was your plan yeah bad plan wasn't that  excited about kissing her anyway  oh I'm sorry am I not your diet yeah mmm  that's not what I said are you only into  like hockey groupies you would prefer  that I have a bucket of chicken wings  under one arm and a big gulp under the  other is that what you like  what does everything always have to be a  question with you